In the last exercise, we used alpha and jitter to reduce
over plotting, but it turns out that there's more that we can
do. Let's hear from Mora about how she used her domain
knowledge and a transformation to make an adjustment to her scatter plot.
>> The next thing that I did, was
to take again, the perceived audience size, and their
actual audience size, but this time I transformed
the axes. So this time, it's as a percentage
of their friend count. Some people in this study had
50 friends, some had 100, some had 2,000, and so,
it actually makes more sense to think about your audience
size as a percentage of the possible audience. All of
the people in the study had shared their post with
friends only privacy, so you'd expect that it would be
bounded by their friend count. So, what we found when
we plotted it this way was that all of the points
are below this line of perfect accuracy, this diagonal line, really
well below. And one other thing I should note about this
plot, we actually ran two different surveys. We ran one survey
where we asked people in a single post, how many people
do you think saw, saw your post? But we also asked
a different set of people, in general, how many people do
you think see the content that you share on Facebook? So
that's what this plot is showing. This is the in general
question, and their guesses are a little bit
higher. But still, people typically think people that maybe
10% of their friends see their content when in
reality it's more like 40% or 50%, even 60%
of their friends will see their content in
a given month. So that's what this plot is
showing, is the percentage of friends who actually saw
their content in the last month, again, they're underestimating.